let's jump to this story we got a couple
political uh bits to jump on we have the
post millennial Trump blasts attempt to
illegally remove his name from ballot in
Colorado on phony Insurrection claims
and ladies and gentlemen we have
received a a a spot in the books of
history at the trial for Donald Trump
over whether or not he should be allowed
on the ballot they played this clip
which I will play for you now of a show
you've probably seen with cash Patel
here we go I have to wonder cash if
everything I said before about people
being too stupid it's in fact that the
leadership is as stupid right of course
the leadership is no no the leadership
is evil they're not stupid there's a
distinction I've worked with all of
these people they are pure evil the only
thing the Pelos and the Schumer and and
the like care about in the world is
being glorified in the media that's it
what's my next headline what's my next
payday how do I scam the stock market
with my husband how do I come out on top
and be speaker of the house for more
than basically a decade that is the
track that people come in behind them on
and saying I want to be the next her I
want to be the next him they are evil
that's the problem the people that
follow them yes stupid yep stupid and
they're evil so that was played that
clip it's funny because as soon as cash
said they're evil I laughed with myself
laughing in the clip in the same way I
thought it was hilarious and shout out
to Phil leonti for his cameo in the in
the Trump trial uh this is the current
state of American politics we have this
uh uh this tweet here from Dean Phillips
he says in one graph this is why I'm
running for president we could be
sleepwalking towards disaster we need an
Open Primary and I hope other qualified
Democrats still jump in here it is from
Bloomberg News morning Council Trump is
leading in five of seven swing States
and Michigan's a tie so you've got in um
Pennsylvania Wisconsin North Carolina
Arizona and Georgia Trump is ahead in in
Michigan it's tied in Nevada Biden is
leading in all altogether Trump is Up by
Four Points so why are they trying to
remove Trump from the ballot in
Colorado I think Colorado isn't one of
these states but they want to make sure
that the popular vote count is as low as
possible for Donald Trump and they want
to him they want to uh exhaust
his resources and force him into legal
battles the problem however is this is
basically giving Trump a 24 seven rally
I like I get it it's they're they're
trying to stop it by any means necessary
but it's like a Chinese finger trap
problem they keep saying we're going to
put him in court then okay now the media
has got a camera in Trump's face again
letting him say whatever he wants and it
makes me think the people in Colorado
whose tax dollars being spent on this
trial right do they look at this and say
yes this is our biggest priority if you
had told me they were doing something
similar in like maybe 2016 right when
people were really 2020 when people were
really orange man bad really freaking
out about Trump maybe I would would have
said oh yeah the average Colorado and
feels like this is the most important
use but I don't feel that way especially
postco and especially since you know
Denver in particular has been really
hard hit by uh illegal immigration there
are a lot of issues that I'm sure people
in Colorado would rather see their
government focusing on and instead this
is what they're being told their
government's number one the legal
apparatus of their government's number
one priority is right now that would
seem just F satisfactory for me I don't
know how you feel about it no I I agree
and I think what the American people are
seeing is just a a spending spre by the
bid Administration to your point you
know the the average everyday American
now is paying a lot more attention to
what's going on politically and I think
Trump once again resonates with the
common American and you know the
two-tier justice system the guy's been
on trial since 2016 and you know you can
only run it so many times without people
paying some attention and the more they
um you know the more they see it the
more drawn in they are and I I just
think Trump has put on a master class on
how to deal with the media he's put on a
master class on how to deal with these
court systems and he's very transparent
and he speaks his mind and I think
people appreciate it I know I do he's
definitely weathered this uh I I would
say there's great words to describe it
but very impressively I would say his
mind is still very clear I can hear the
fatigue but I mean God anyone going
through this would be fatigued I'm just
at the Elmo meme phase in this one you
know that that Elmo with fire rising up
behind him that's where I'm at with this
and I'm like Halloween costume next year
at this point I really don't care what
Trump says or does I just despise these
people so much that I just want Trump to
go in and do whatever he wants because
it would be the most irritating thing in
the world for them and I know that's how
people felt in 2016 and 2020 I didn't
feel that way in 2016 I was like it's
all stupid but there were a lot of
people who were looking at Donald Trump
as this Raging Bull and they were
laughing like I hope this guy gets to do
it everyone I'm at the point where I'm
just like I am so fed up with these
trials with these lies the manipulation
I'm just like can we get two or three
three trumps can we get the whole Trump
family can we get where is where is got
an idea we're constantly trying to
figure out who the VP is going to be
Trump trump Trump trump just do it I
don't care which one it is can you run
with your son can your son be your vice
president any one of them any one of
thems are not from the same state Trum
Trum but I don't think they are she's
the only one in yeah well she was North
Carolina I heard rumors that Lara uh la
la trp might seriously consider running
in North Carolina because that's where
she's from be VP so interesting just
more trumps I just want I just these
awful people who exploit the system to
enrich themselves through the stock
market and all this awful garbage and
then we're watching them lie cheat and
steal because the American people are
finally like guys you ripped us off for
long enough all we're doing now is
saying Trump's going to build some some
border security and we're going to bring
manufacturing back none of these wars
and y'all couldn't even have it y'all
got away with ripping us off for for
Generations stealing
these these these these ridiculous stock
trading Deals they know what's going on
they're passing the laws they're
introducing them they are lying cheating
and stealing and all we ask is that some
dude gets in for eight little old years
and get us some border security and
brings a manufacturing back and you said
f you to all of us and I'm just like at
this point I just hope it's Trump 20124
28 32 36 Etc just just never ending I'm
just I'm just so D with seen the Mel
Gibson meme where it's like me voting
for Trump in 2016 is just Mel Gibson
smiling and me voting for no in 2020 and
then me voting for Trump in in 24 and
it's got you know Mel Gibson with the
brave
whatever that's how the American people
feel man what is it about VI do you guys
how do you feel about V and what I love
him I do too I love him do you think he
like do you throw your support behind
him um or would you pick Trump do you
have a preference um you know my my
loyalties to to Trump I think he
deserves another four years for all all
of the reasons we just said um but you
know V I met him a few years back when
you know he wasn't running for politics
he spoke at a Lincoln Day dinner locally
and uh took a couple minutes of time to
talk to me and he's he's a guy from Ohio
I think he's uh you know the the young
articulate strong um American Dream type
of guy that we need and he's he could be
he could be VP great I that's what he's
he said he wouldn't take it he wouldn't
but he's probably the best person right
now realistically in terms of POS
positioning would you know it it it is
tough to figure out like who really
would be the best VP but VI outside of
him saying he doesn't want it probably
his best positioned for it I know I know
his team is is is that that's their
Focus right yeah I mean I talked I
talked to his team they're great people
right but I mean you know the the long
game for them they're they're supporting
Trump I mean V is supporting Trump right
he's never bashed him but V's also 38
yeah and I think the reality he knows
he's not going to defeat Trump right and
I think V's uh intention was to kneecap
Rona santis in the debates and he did a
hell job doing it Well Ron did it to
himself I'm going to say Ron I wanted to
love you dude you went on Patrick B
David show where have you been come on
man just relax and sit down and talk to
us wor he's the governor of Florida in
Florida Patrick B Davids in Miami it was
like I'm not gonna this I'll never do
this right jenier came on the culture
War podcast I said thank you I know you
host your own show taking time off your
your show to do my show is a favor to me
I get it Ronda santz is in Florida it's
easy for him to do pbd yeah but you put
in what would it come to fly out here
you put in like eight tops 18 hours of
work you're going to get 700,000 hours
of product out of it from watch I got I
gotta be honest I gotta be honest about
this you I I Patrick Bet David is much
more brutal than I am he he doesn't he
like I I give people leeway and some
people argue I should not yeah you know
a lot of people were saying that when
jener came on the show I should have
just gone at him way heavier and they
were like Why didn't it pop off and I
was like I was trying to prevent it from
getting into that heated debate
and were were a few points where we
talked about George Floyd anded Ary
where J got really heated and I pulled
away from it trying to keep things
Patrick bed David the way he went after
Anthony Weiner I mean Ron had to know
that pbd is not going to let him walk
away from the high heel scandal in this
way I got to be honest if Ron came here
I would not drag him I would have not I
would not have done that you wouldn't
have had a set a far shoes like like it
was funny it's a it's a clip obviously
his team had planned it even though he's
like phrasing the like I'm sure you
heard about this thing like you know
this Scandal about your shoes or
whatever like patri Davis knew what he
was doing he knew he was going to do it
with second you know he got the S it's a
different style of show it's not the way
you operate no one who comes on the show
will ever be ambushed like that and I I
mean no disrespect to pbd I think it was
masterfully done and I he's pointing out
great criticism but that's just not how
we would we do things and I'm a big fan
of of the work that he does I think he's
a genius but it's funny to me seeing
that I'm like the disantis people are
are banned from coming on this show
but by own team by their own team right
right yeah yeah yeah we want them on we
want dis sers and and his people to come
on but they' they've refused they told
their staff they're not allowed and then
he decided to go on value tment instead
where it's like yo that's the frying pan
man that's like pbd is not it's an
example of the poor team that Ronda
santz has around I mean he's in he's in
an echo chamber right I've met Ronda
Sanz before I liked him before the
election man I was just thinking like
this guy you know if he would have done
what Reagan you know um did to uh Barry
Goldwater right he could he could have
passed the torch or not passed the torch
but he could have had the torch passed
to him on the back end right and he
didn't do that and I think everything
about his campaign is a shining example
of the consultant class ruining Politics
the guy has been in an echo chamber his
entire campaign you can see when he
steps out because when he steps out
that's when he's you know out of his
Zone and he makes you know a lot of
mistakes but man dude only if right I
mean he would have been the perfect guy
in 2028 but now it's too late no you
know what I really do think I know I've
said it several times in the past couple
weeks but I think the the donors went to
run and convinced him to run to make
sure he would not be VP a trump DeSantis
ticket is unbeatable and that's what
everyone had been saying the year before
you know I've talked about I'll talk you
know I'm talking to a guy I'm hanging
out at MGM National Harbor and there's a
guy he's like I hate Trump oh but I
can't vote for Biden and I'm like what
about desantis's like oh yeah I'd vote
for DeSantis for sure and then I say
what if it's Trump D santis Trump
president T VP he goes yeah I'd vote for
it he's like with the santis there I
think I could do it and I think the
establishment saw the writing on the
wall that Ron is willing to play ball
with whatever's going to get him the
victory so in Florida he's going along
with with with core right culture War
talking points and he's putting his
policies forward and they're like uh oh
that means that if he teams up with
Trump he's going to just say yes sir to
Trump and he's going to go along with
this to try and be successful and build
and build a career up so they go to Ron
and they say no no you should be
president you should run and they're
laughing at him behind the scenes
they're like this guy's an idiot he's
actually going to do it he think he's
going to go up against Trump oh I got an
idea tell him to wear high heels tell
him to wear high heels and then don't
show him the videos and then send him to
pbd on purpose this is the point Jen
yuger comes on this show I basically let
him speak we have a little bit of
disagreements and arguments but there's
a lot of stuff I could have brought up
that we didn't bring up thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at
timcast.net uncensored membersonly shows
exclusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next
time